- [Narrator] Welcome to
Oregon's Big Foot Highway.
For decades maybe even
longer, people have ventured
into the mountains and
woods outside of Portland
to prove that mankind is
not alone in the woods.
(men howling)
(man howling)
Okay, so far mankind hasn't yet proved
that Bigfoot exists.
But for one club of long
time intrepid Bigfooters,
the truth is still out there
and its a great excuse to go camping.
(men howling)
Joe Beelart believes in
the existence of Bigfoot.
He wrote a book about it.
And he claims to have had
more than one sighting.
- In the second instance, he was here to
your cameraman from me.
But I got to say I don't
think he was quite as hairy.
When people are skeptical, I tell them
they're like UFOs and ghosts.
People see them but
there's no widely accepted
scientific proof.
- [Narrator] Joe is not alone.
He belongs to a group he dubs
the Clackamas Sasquatchians.
Clackamas for the county he lives in.
- [Joe] We're actually
in the heart land of
Bigfoot activity.
- [Narrator] And
Sasquatchians for Sasquatch.
- Bigfoot and Sasquatch
are synonymous terms.
In my group we're Bigfooters.
We just go out and do the job.
- We put ourselves out there.
We make a bunch of noise,
play a bunch of music
and let the landscape
know that we're there
and then later, in the evening
that's when the strangest
things would take place.
Something's walking around your tent
and its like, what is that?
- And that's the excitement of it.
Give you the heebie jeebies (laughs).
- [Narrator] Their backgrounds are varied.
PhDs, ex-military, a
retired science teacher.
And a few engineers.
And most have a specialty.
- My specialty is putting out offerings.
If you come back and there's
something laying there
where that apple was, then probably it was
one of our barefoot friends.
- I would like to set up a
camp in a comfortable position.
I don't try to chase them down.
I don't try to make a lot of noise.
Maybe they make a hooray of some kind,
but is it a Sasquatch
that's making these noises?
We didn't see it.
We can't say that for sure.
But its a great hobby.
(distant howling)
- That sounded Squatchy.
I mean I don't feel any
Squatchy vibes but...
- Well as far as my specialty
with Joe's club is concerned,
I just get a vibe.
And I can tell when they're around.
Usually they put out a vibe
and I'm really sensitive to that.
- This is Squatchy for sure.
- [Narrator] Whether the
Squatchy vibes are flowing
is besides the point
for the Sasquatchians.
The point is they are together
in their favorite place.
- Why do I love doing this?
The flora and the fauna, the butterflies,
the night sky, its all up there.
- People ask me if I believe in Bigfoot,
and I never give a definitive answer.
But Bigfoot is in my mind
10% of everything that we do
to enjoy each other's company.
- Bigfooting helped me kick the cancer
spending four months in a hospital,
getting chemotherapy was hell
and what made me get through
that was imagining me
getting me back up to the
woods and visiting my friends.
Hopefully I'll get Bigfoot sitting around the
campfire with me one day.
(pleasant music)